[Music]
RKO Pictures there are actually several
things wrong with that but mainly radio
pictures books reading narration of
reading this is the calmest happy dog
I've ever seen are we sure he's not dead
also evil stepmother is so evil it makes
you wonder which dude was able to get it
up for her to produce two daughters but
the stepmothers true nature was revealed
you mean evilly stroking a cat with a
perpetual scowl on her face didn't tip
that off ever bird Butler's alarm clock
Birds these birds are dicks can't tell
cuz if you tell a wish it won't come
true our dreams wishes dammit there's a
song for this oh look there's a mouse
and he's stoned does she not regularly
get bird and mouse droppings on her
sheets and bedding yeah let's blame the
clock when it was a couple of birds that
woke you up sure is lucky that these are
the nice kind of mice or else this might
be considered an infestation other than
her singing which is fair are these
animals compensated in any way for doing
so much of the work for her morning
routine disappointing sponge baths look
fun for the whole family aside
Cinderella appears to have zero side
boob in this shot you might think I have
a need to see cartoon nudity I don't I
saw heavy metal and it's like jacking
off to crayons my point is if you're
gonna have a scene like this you can't
pretend Cinderella's chest is made up of
a solid black line Mouse undergarments
well that makes 167 then house plays the
pronoun game with Cinderella Cinderella
assumes she for some reason because this
game is awesome green cloaked Mouse
flashes Cinderella to emphasize the
mouse's a heat which I don't know how
that communicates gender but I guess
that's how it was done in 1954 sure
we'll call you Gus how is Gus short for
Octavius we were told the house had
fallen into disrepair after Cinderella's
dad died but it looks pretty damn good
for disrepair
come here they named the cat Lucifer
that's not a nickname either they
actually named the cat Lucifer also cats
aren't known to come when called by name
or even understand their own names like
if your cat is named pretty you could
also call kitty titty years and have the
same odds of that cat coming to you
anyway I digress so what you don't want
to lose a nice warm bed you'd better get
rid of those dreams but a dream is a
wish that your heart makes Cinderella
most cats are lactose intolerant so even
if you're serving an evil cat this is
not a good idea these mice only know one
way out of the castle apparently story
of Cinderella becomes a Tom and Jerry
cartoon there is no reason to get this
close to a cat you're trying to distract
and lure away from the door wig
none at all Cinderella is feeding three
different species the same kind of food
strike that four species cheese overdose
stupidest Mouse in history somehow fails
to grab a single piece of food despite
having started out next to a fucking
pile of that then Cinderella over feeds
Gus four times his bodyweight like she's
the killer in seven what a dumbass damn
this big-ass evil cat gets knocked out
by things normal cats would either avoid
or get hit by and run into five
different rooms before stopping that's
not possible
what the hell kind of breakfast is this
hot water a teacup no sugar or cream or
lemon or anything at all to put in the
tea hell I don't even actually see any
teabags and then we have what chicken
broth foreshadowing it's hard to believe
an hour and 14 minute movie had so
little story that it needed this much
Mouse plot this is not where the hole
was before if you want to say it's so
dark I can't see the stepmother fine
just don't tell me it lights up like
magic I don't know where what stepmother
must keep that crane by her bed because
it wasn't on the trees Cinderella was
carrying which means it's spoiled and
gross all the eligible maid
I happened to be there why palms are so
interesting isn't it well this is gay
night
how long have you known your son is
coming home you're just now thinking of
arranging a ball on the day he's coming
back
Cinderella leaves a pile of dirt in the
dustpan just lying around so that evil
cats can perform mischief the animation
sequence and this is awesome
and the song is pretty but damn it has
four words in the entire song repeated
over and over mice openly walk around in
the main part of the house knowing full
well there are four living things who
hate them here and could discover them
at any time what's this we hear about
stitching a dress well she said
[Music]
stepsister ex machina this movie should
just be called mice they're able to get
on these beads using this tiny sack and
Gus's tail I counted them that's more
than 40 here
I'm calling bullshit on cartoon logic
over a minute and a half of Bert Mouse
dressmaking I would removed all the sins
from this movie plus any remaining ones
left in the feature if the needle had
stabbed this mouse in the head
apparently even in whatever castle era
this is dudes anacondas didn't want none
unless they had bonds hon Cinderella
doesn't immediately run for her life
when his sudden person appears fairy
godmothers must be pretty damn common I
guess Hogwarts is right around the
corner it also explains why a Gryffindor
ended up in the Slytherin house at some
points in Duralast I wonder why the
fairy godmother waited until some ball
to show up and offer help after like a
lifetime of torture and abuse this
nonsensical alliteration works to turn
pumpkins into carriages mice and horses
and horses into people I don't know how
the words know how to change what into
what but it sure is catchy also fairy
godmother creates a world where if
Cinderella fell in love with her
coachman she technically be falling in
love with a horse no judgments I'm just
saying that's the world we're living in
right now
magical Project Runway glass slippers
doesn't sound dangerous at all why why
not 1 a.m. or 3:30 3 a.m.
are never arbitrary magical obstacle is
arbitrary delay this carriage is moving
Cinderella would sustained brain
injuries her dress would be torn and her
hair would be a freaking mess
she looks hideous she doesn't even have
blond hair yeah hot women are boring
what a dick this dude is I can't decide
if this guy has too many guards or too
many stairs he stops
looks the day I accept narration from an
asshole wearing a monocle that's the day
I give up cinema sentence the good he
can tell that Cinderella is awesome from
this distance because in all the
kingdoms she's the only blonde at least
she's the only blond with those kind of
birthing hips oh by the way my name is
Cinderella I know it's awkward when you
just start dancing and don't even
introduce yourself or speak perfect
people rarely need to do that after two
minutes well I don't know where the fuck
we are now but maybe Elrond will show us
the way out of here by morning but
you're in love that's for sure that's
the disadvantage of the start dancing
and never talk method of courtship um no
it was midnight 75 seconds ago that's in
movie time too if it's still midnight
then why is my mo quite turning into a
gremlin so easily I knew I shouldn't
trust town clocks when it came to
late-night feedings so why did
everything turn back to normal but the
slipper she lost remains it's beautiful
glass self it makes me wonder if she had
bibbidi-bobbidi-boo the prince with all
the clothes on the ground of state
bibbidi-bobbidi-boo no that's not what
it looked like when she changed back
take that hard-working animators thank
you so much thanks for showing up after
17 years of my life at least 10 of them
under the horrible rule of my stepmother
to give me 3 hours of magic that you
could easily have adjusted to 2:00 or
3:00 a.m. because your magic this king
is upset at the duke scene is just plain
stupid and doesn't belong in this movie
okay I said it and should and it's crazy
it doesn't by the way the other way you
could figure out who the slipper belongs
to is to find the one blond girl in the
entire kingdom the Princess Bride
I love that movie oh wait Cinderella is
now under such a spell she gives clues
to her stepmother that she was the
princess dance partner from last night
although let's be honest she could have
already known due to I don't know her
appearance many famous people have
stayed in this castle in olden times
including
Abraham Lincoln evil stepmother in
ridiculously lucky fashion aimlessly
props herself in perfect my stealing
keys position what mice have x-ray
vision now proclamation about a fucking
shoe fitting is so long it allows the
mice to do this stepmother doesn't
notice a giant mouse in the saucer t
drop defies the laws of gravity if you
cut all the mouse footage out of this
movie you'd literally be left with a 14
minute short film look don't put a
situation in a movie that is this
impossible with the time given and then
tell me Cinderella gets out of her damn
room before the Duke leaves and the mice
climb all this way in the time it takes
for the lone remaining sister to try on
the shoe mice have sudden forks and
scissors all over their home to go
attack the cat with no wonder this dude
has been out this all night he spends
ten minutes with each girl trying to jam
on a shoe that obviously doesn't fit
fitting in for the cat if he shows up
alive at any point we'll know he was
buried in the pet cemetery I know
terrible how they can only settle this
with a shoe fitting and not any other
aspects of her features terrible huh she
never once said her name so that this
was the only way they could find her but
you see I have the other slipper
now there's no way to verify that the
slipper is the same size as the one that
broke but I guess these are the only
glass slippers ever made because they
would be uncomfortable if in real life
foot fetish yeah we're married what's
your name again
[Music]
why have a ballroom with no balls ever
since cinemasins began the most
requested thing has been TV since and
now it's a reality click the link in the
description below to check it out and
now the audio outtakes
I wanna ride the pony
[Music]
[Applause]
Harker oh yes and the tapestries and the
draperies this is a castle isn't it
there are tapestries wild geese that fly
with the moon on their wings these are a
few of my favorite see that yes the Frog
is certainly taking the meeting on this
show it's hard to feel sorry for him
we take a beating every show hey less
old as time
[Music]
[Applause]
there is still a chance that one of you
can get it fairest of them all